Майже три місяці тому DW перевіряла, як працює система прокату перших громадських велосипедів.
Нині ми з'ясуємо: чи був пілотний проект вдалим для столиці.
У перші дні після старту здавалося, що проект не приживеться.
У мережі ледь не щодня з’являлися фото пошкоджених велосипедів.
Хулігани ламали спиці, сидіння, відкручували дзвоник.
А тут камера зафіксувала, як невідомі спершу ”скотили” велосипед по сходах,
а потім втопили його у Дніпрі.
Злочинцями виявилися підлітки.
Такий велосипед коштує понад 500 євро, тож ремонт влітає в копієчку.
У жовтні на Троєщині дві станції прокату громадських велосипедів взагалі закрили.
Тут їх не лише ламали, але й крали.
Одного зі злочинців ще шукають, іншого впіймали одразу.
Допоміг небайдужий свідок, який зателефонував у поліцію.
За таку крадіжку злочинцю загрожує від 5 до 8 років позбавлення волі.
Та, попри дрібне хуліганство, Nextbike у Києві працюватиме і далі.
За три місяці зі ста ”вижило” 96 велосипедів. Це доволі непогані результати, кажуть у компанії.
Перевершено очікування.
Звісно, що є проблеми, є здобутки, люди сприйняли дуже позитивно,
тому продовжувати є сенс і рухатися далі.
Зараз із київською інвестиційною агенцією розробляємо документи,
вони допоможуть у наступному році запустити сервіс уже не пілотний,
а розгалужену мережу з набагато більшою кількістю велосипедів.
Навесні після домовленостей з інвесторами кількість громадських велосипедів у Києві
хочуть збільшити до двох або й навіть трьох тисяч.
Розшириться також мережа станцій, де їх можна буде залишити.
У п’ятірку найактивніших користувачів сервісу входить велоактивістка,
чиновниця Департаменту транспортної інфраструктури Києва Анна Даниленко.
Каже, навіть попри відсутність інфраструктури
кияни готові користуватися новим видом транспорту.
Міська влада тим часом намагається зробити поїздки на велосипедах безпечним.
У вересні було ухвалено нові будівельні норми для ремонту доріг.
Ці нові норми дають нам можливість звужувати вулиці для того, щоб
зменшувати трохи швидкість для машин
і вивільняти більше простору для велосипедистів і пішоходів.
Адже саме ці категорії в нас у місті є пріоритетними за стратегією розвиту Києва.
З цього року уКМДА проектують три магістральні веломаршрути.
Вони поєднають Оболонь з Подолом, Виноградар і Солом’янку з центром.
А з наступного року заплановано ще 11 велодоріг.
Які об'єднають Київ цілісною веломережею.
Якщо мерія дасть гроші на реалізацію проекту,
то перші три маршрути, довжиною майже в 30 кілометрів, з’являться вже за рік.
А поки - кияни та гості міста маневрують між а втомобілями
та знайомляться з послугою оренди велобайків.
Скачали програму, ось намагаємося зняти з блокування.
Це дуже корисно і добре, що це є. Я сама не з Києва а зі Львова.
І у Львові трохи по-іншому працює. Але сам сервіс прикольний.
У системі зареєстровано понад 18 тисяч користувачів.
А в пік сезону велосипеди орендували до чотирьохсот разів на день.
Схоже, що звичний для Європи громадський велосипед поволі стає популярним і в Києві.